thank you
[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
you're gonna share one of these episodes
this is probably the one to share
oh I think I drank a whole bottle of
Jaeger last night
[Music]
it's gonna be an interesting morning but
we're gonna get through it
I'm gonna show you some [__]
I really since
um I don't know it's about uh four or
five o'clock yesterday I have not even
looked at the news and this morning I
was really trying to I don't know if you
could tell I was trying to um sober up
to be on the broadcast today you know I
don't miss a single [__] show you
know this Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific right here
on YouTube Twitter and twitch so don't
forget to subscribe it's free
do me the favor today to subscribe
subscribe to the YouTube channel the
Tony Michaels do I look hungover I don't
know I've still feel
hungover
yeah someone says I smell like booze
yeah
I definitely smell like booze I tried to
get it all over me but I couldn't holy
[__] someone says a whole bottle of
Jager yeah
there's a lot of shots last night it is
my it is my birthday uh today I am 38
years old
a lot of people
don't know that but last night we
celebrated uh as we do almost every
Wednesday we go to karaoke so a bunch of
our friends came out
and made sure to buy me Shots
um sometimes two at a time so it was uh
I'm not sure exactly how many I did and
I I know I ate a a part of a gummy but I
don't know if there's more of those I
don't know it was a great night I had a
lot of fun I don't remember the fun
but I'm sure I had fun so
thank you for all the happy birthdays in
the chat I really appreciate it okay
we're gonna try I'm I swear to you and
we're gonna try to do a show today it's
gonna happen
it just uh maybe a little uh
last night
someone's talking about my eyes yeah I'm
I'm telling you man this is uh this is
how it works I want to thank you guys
the audience
um I actually
I think it was yesterday we had 198
members on patreon I believe
and um
yesterday we got over 200 so I want to
thank you guys for getting us over 200
on patreon the uh the [__] fam over
there on patreon the patreon members
thank you very much uh that helps out a
lot uh with the show as we're trying to
get to where we can go to three hours I
would like to sometime by the end of the
summer definitely definitely by next
year when we get into the 2024 election
cycle to be at three hours a day so we
would come on the same exact time but
we'd be doing three hours a day
instead of two but again if you're gonna
share an episode this might be it I
might say some really crazy outlandish
[__] who knows who knows what I'm gonna
do or what I'm gonna say you know what I
mean thank you for all the birthday
wishes I really appreciate it I really
do appreciate it
thank you very much thank you very much
I I'm just glad all of you weren't at
the bar last night because I I have a
feeling I had to drink three bottles of
Jaeger
instead of just one I don't know how
many shots I had but it was it was a lot
it was a lot
whew okay so let's get down to the
business you notice the thumbnail was uh
Jamal Bowman
um he he was standing in the hallway as
the Republican cowards were walking past
him yesterday and he was talking about
uh what they aren't doing
as far as reasonable gun safety and
Thomas Massey thought it was a great
idea to stop to stop and and argue with
with representative Bowman he thought
that was a good idea uh he obviously
doesn't know who uh Bowman is he doesn't
know that Bowman is a is a teacher a
former principal and he's been in
schools
so we're going to watch that video also
I got some video to show you of uh
Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren bobert
of all people these two being [__]
morons in committee meetings oh my God
you'll never believe it it's like this
footage is just not gonna exist anywhere
oh okay so uh the other the other one I
want to show you that's going on right
now as we speak is the weaponization
committee
they're weaponizing government
um so and there there's a few moments in
there that I want to show you how Jim
Jordan is failing at his job and it's
not surprising that Jim I don't report
sex crimes Jordan is failing at his job
and it it's just that is par for the
course
for that [__] box so we're gonna show
that as well
I'm gonna try to show you as many Clips
as I can today
uh someone sent me Margie sent me the um
a 14-minute clip of a king Jeffrey some
maybe we'll just let Hakeem take over
the show you know what I mean
we'll just let him take over the show
let him maybe I'll go uh visit the
porcelain gods for a few minutes and a
lot of King Jeffries take over the show
no Gabe Sanchez will be here with us at
the bottom of the hour I just need a lot
of water
a lot of water
um
I'm so happy you're here with us today
and I'm glad that I am I I peeled myself
out of bed and sobering myself up with
food shower
water and coffee I got my coffee here
too don't worry I'll be all right don't
worry I think
[Music]
um
so um
let's see what what else is in the news
today yeah I know it's the 30 minutes
usually I'm on point but I gotta be oh
oh the Q Anon Shaman uh I I guess is uh
being released early is that right
is that what they're saying uh he's
being released early
from uh Federal Prison
uh let's see it's uh 14 months early
than expected
um this is uh pretty typical
um for a federal
inmate where they're released early they
go to a halfway house
and then a lot of times they'll actually
serve the rest of their time on an ankle
bracelet and home which you know and
this is this is a par for the course for
federal inmate this isn't like
something like they're taking pity just
on him
right
someone says that's [__] Kim says
that's [__] well I mean it may be
[__] but it's just what happens with
the federal inmates
just happens now it's not like federal
inmates don't have the possibility of
parole right like when you go to federal
prison there's no parole
there there's there's your paper which
is your you know your probation
after right so like you got to be on
supervised supervised release after uh
but Bureau prisons
isn't actually going to release him more
than likely he's still under the
supervision of Bureau of Prisons unless
they hand it over to like a home
confinement
um two
the Department of Justice which is
pre-trial and and probation federal
probation because there's no federal
parole it doesn't exist it's not like a
State Crime where you go into prison for
15 years and they parole you in in six
and there isn't they they got rid of
federal parole back in the 80s I believe
if I'm not mistaken maybe it was even
the crime bill in the 1990s I don't know
exactly
um but there is no
there is no possibility of parole so
he's not getting out on parole he's
still under the supervision he's still
incarcerated in other words because he
still has to be an inmate somewhere
whether it be at a halfway house or at
uh if they if Bureau prisons turns him
over to the
um the Department of Justice where his
pre-trial or his probation officer at
the pre-trial probation office at the
federal courthouse where he's at and
takes over his case
Hill so uh Jacob chansley the Q a and
Shaman the Buffalo guy you know what I'm
talking about
this [__] Wackadoo I actually I'm I'm
not opposed to him being out and and
using his first amendment right
um I actually think this might be a good
thing
I think this might be a good thing folks
because he's the crazy of the crazy
right well at least that's the
perception we've watched a lot of crazy
videos of people at Trump rallies right
and this guy was one of these he's a
Cuban honor he's a [__] Jew and honor
his self-proclaimed we don't call him
the Q Anon Shaman as a dig that that's
his
whoosh uh anyways so he's the crazy of
the crazy right
now maybe just maybe I don't know
I doubt it but maybe just maybe
he got over he's crazy uh while he was
locked up
and when he comes out maybe he'll just
maybe he'll see the light and he'll
start talking
um some some sense into some of these
other people who used to follow him
doubt it but we'll see now let's see
what else is in the news uh let's do
besides Jim Jordan
Alan weisselberg's in the news oh yes
yes yesterday
um it looks like the uh
um
uh it looks like
Alan weisselberg the CFO of the Trump
organization you know the games they say
Rikers and it's no longer being
represented by Trump's attorneys so
Trump has yanked away Alan weisselberg's
attorneys which seems significant I
don't know maybe maybe just maybe
there's movement in the Alvin Bragg case
at the Manhattan DA's office uh we we
know that they are taking a little bit
of a Hiatus it says it was planned I
guess maybe I don't know again you had
to forgive me yesterday uh it's kind of
a blur with uh with the
with the news
as is my mind but
um so but I think that could be
significant in that case uh I think a
lot of people
I think a lot of people are
are underestimating the charges that
Alvin Bragg has in his pocket
um again we know Trump's
normal obstruction right we know this
he's he's an obstructor by [__]
nature he obstructs every investigation
that's into him rather it's civil
whether it's criminal whether it's
any investigation really any lawsuit
he's obstruct abstract obstruct obstruct
that's why he would say no obstruction
no collusion no obstruction no collusion
because that's exactly what he he
obstructs and he colludes like it's it's
not [__] hard to see the projection
there uh so I know I think people should
stop underestimating exactly what Alvin
Bragg has the other thing too is I
believe that maybe just maybe there's
new evidence of new crimes that have
happened very recently
I mean how how can anyone not think that
Donald Trump is still criming
because you know the right wing wants to
say oh the hush money payment the hush
money payment
about the hush money payment listen I
actually don't believe that Alvin Bragg
is going to bring a charge that has
anything to do with the check that was
written to Stormy Daniels
by Michael Cohen that hush money payment
I think it's all the crime after that
all of it after that is the charges that
Alvin Bragg's gonna bring because I
don't even know that the hush money
payment is actually illegal
I mean I I don't know that the hush
money payment that was made to Stormy
Daniels the check made out two Stormy
Daniels from Michael Cohen was actually
illegal I don't know that that it's
everything after that
that becomes a crime
right
so I I don't think it has I don't think
Alvin Bragg is
um focused in on the actual payment that
was made for Michael Cohen
to Stormy Daniels and besides
stormy excuse me Michael Cohen went to
federal prison for the payment made to
Stormy Daniels he went to prison for
that crime so it's all the crime after
that possibly uh that breaks state law
and I they keep talking about the the
you know this campaign and election and
money and listen I think it's
obstruction this guy obstructs that's
what he does
that's that's what he thinks he's best
at is obstructing
it's it's not and and maybe even you
know like
the the [__] lying on his [__]
taxes and deducting it as some kind of
legal expense that's probably I mean the
state of New York probably wants their
money
also and pro oh proper you know what I
mean
so fraud and obstruction and collusion
is what this guy does that's what he
does
I don't know why this is why we still
are arguing about who Donald Trump is we
know who he is he's a [__] scumbag
um so it looks like uh Alan weiselberg's
gonna
hey boy I don't think that's I don't
think that's a good thing that's not
good for Trump
um
that's not good for Trump if Alan
weisenberg is getting new attorneys and
he's not paying for him anymore either
that he just
he just did
he's just broke
Trump he's broke and he can't afford to
pay for Alan weiselberg's attorneys I
mean he doesn't pay for anything anyways
did you see this video with Thomas
Massey
and Jamal Bowman
Jamal is a uh a former
uh educator
he's actually a principal
a middle school principal
and he's a congressman
um and yesterday and on his Twitter bio
it's he says causing good trouble and
yesterday he caused Great and good
trouble yesterday in the halls of
Congress as the Republicans slanked by
those [__] cowards and he called them
out with with gusto
um we gotta I keep telling you this
they said it yesterday I tweeted it
yesterday we have to get loud
it's this is not
again this is not an issue where the
majority of the country is not with us
they are with us on this [__] issue
the I the idea somehow that that
we're just gonna let
anybody and everybody whoever wants to
have a semi-automatic weapon of War to
take it anywhere they want and mow down
as many people as they want
and we're just gonna put up with that I
think it's bone-headed at best
now we have a lot of very very powerful
forces working against us one of those
forces is the Republican Party the the
real America First Nazi party
and they're hell-bent
on making sure
that we have more access
to guns than we do to
Healthcare Women's Health Care Services
um then we do to books
children's books to be specific and the
drag shows
math
I mean they're really concerned about
all these things
d-e-i-c-r-t wokism
but guns that Mo children down and
murder rip apart children's bodies
they're not so concerned about
and the reason why is because it's good
for their pocket it's good for the the
gun manufacturer's pocket
the gun manufacturers
put some of that money towards the gun
lobby which the gun lobby has had a a
very powerful
Hammer to swing in Washington and in our
state houses more than Washington even
there's a lot of gun regulation that
happens on the state level
or lack thereof
they they loved it they loved the
release
I mean Florida Florida now if you're
breathing it's required that you carry a
weapon I think I think you actually to
to actually enter in Florida when you
cross the border you have to you know
get out of your car and wave the gun
around and fire it in the air a few
times I think that's the new law
if not it soon will be down in Florida
and then everyone's trying out Florida
Florida you know what I mean but here's
the thing is that
most Americans
aren't against people having guns right
like that's rather you [__] like it
or not most Americans are not against
people having guns we have a very very
deep rooted gun culture in this country
it's one of the problems is white gun
culture in this country you know you
know what I'm talking about white people
like oh I got a problem I can use a gun
to fix it like whatever your problem is
it doesn't matter if you got to go in
and order a Subway sandwich and that's a
problem take your gun you can solve that
problem with your gun probably you don't
like the person down the street ah it's
okay you saw the problem with the gun
you get you get a little pissed off at
the people down at the uh down at the
copy store going to the copy store solve
it with the gun you still got [__]
that's uh um rotten your brain from
years ago [__] that happened to you
years ago at maybe a school or something
then I'd go down go down to the school
and you know take care of that problem
with the gun that's white gun culture
white gun culture says anything any
problem you got cracker any cracker
cracker problem you got you can solve it
with a gun I'm not [__] you this is
white gun culture
I'm not kidding you this is this is the
this is the natural instinct
of
white gun culture
and I say white because I'm telling you
if you're if you're not
if you don't know that that this is
where this deep rooted problem comes
from then you're not paying attention
right
you're you're just you're just not
um so Jamal Bowman is standing and
making this known
and very well known and he he's speaking
to the reporters uh that's the sense I
get he's he's talking to the reporters
as the coward Republicans walk by the
reporters and he's telling the reporters
what to ask them how to hold them
accountable and why we should hold them
accountable I mean children's lives
are at risk here that's that's the thing
Eddie's trying to convey
and
to Bowman's credit it's not like he's
speaking um about something he doesn't
know
what I mean by that is it's about
schools
he was a [__] teacher he was a
goddamn principal at a middle school
how is it that we aren't listening
to Educators how is it that we have gone
in this country
from making sure that the experts
give us expert advice to oh they're
experts well they can't be trusted it's
some part of the cabal
or some crazy [__] you know they say
deep State wokeism they use all these
words listen folks I'm telling you this
and I and I know sometimes it doesn't
feel like it maybe you live in a really
trumpy area
you're always online you're watching
this stuff you're paying attention to
stuff but trust me on this I and trust
me
majority of the American people do not
give two [__] about about what
Republicans are saying about wokism are
woke they don't give a [__] about what
they gotta say about the Deep State they
don't give a [__]
they don't care about what CRT is or Dei
is they don't give a [__]
and it's unfortunate that they don't
right because if more people paid
attention this would be a lot [__]
easier
I mean it would be it would be easier to
get [__] done if people would pay [__]
attention
but that's just not the world we live in
that's not the reality that we have to
work with
people a lot of people don't even know
who the [__] vice president is
they don't they don't [__] know
they don't [__] know who the
secretary of state is they don't they
have no clue what the federal the
Federal Reserve does or doesn't do
they don't know who their governor is
their lieutenant governor they don't
know who the representative is they
don't [__] know
I know it feels like I'm saying people
are stupid it's not that they're stupid
it's it's not that they're stupid people
aren't stupid
it's just we only have enough time
during the day to pay attention to
certain amount of things
and most of the time because we just
haven't been educated through
our shitty education system
about civics
and about forms of government in general
these people just don't give a [__]
now they still vote
and that's where we must get our
messaging right okay that's where like
Jamal Bowman says be [__] loud be
[__] loud ask these [__]
these questions because I'll tell you
even though they people don't give a
[__] about who the politicians are and
who the actual government is which they
should because that's where you get your
results from right
hey
they give a [__] about the issues right
they want their [__] they want their
kids to be safe
they want their kids to be safe in a
school
they don't want to go [__] broke
because of a medical bill
of course
they want a decent [__] wage if
they're gonna go find a goddamn job
right they don't want to have to work
three jobs to make to make it through
they'd much rather have one job work
hard at that job get decent pay at that
job
they want to make sure that if their
kids go to school and go to college that
they're not [__] broke the entirety
of their life because they had to go to
college or a tech school
they really would like I I know a lot of
parents out there would love
that their child start their education
early number one
it's it's very good to just start
education early I mean it's one of the
problems we have with education in this
country if we start too late we start at
five we should be starting these
children at three
but also from three to five that's two
extra years that the parents don't have
to pay for daycare
these are things that um the American
people want right
now I didn't say it like Democrats
normally say it right they're always
like oh we need Universal Pre-K we need
Universal Health Care
we need it we need to raise the minimum
wage you know those trigger words
for people because that's what
Republicans do they don't actually have
policy they don't actually have ideas
what they do is they they message around
words like
CRT D I woke is a deep state
you know they they come up with all
these real catchy things right like woke
woke woke doesn't mean what they say it
means this is what they've turned the
definition into they stole the word
redefined it and now it's something bad
I mean I know what they're saying when
they say woke they mean black people
that's what they mean they mean black
come on
oh I'll show you a video on it I'm gonna
need to show you some videos here in a
minute I'm running out of gas
[Laughter]
um
but uh
this is what they mean this is what they
do
we can do the same thing folks we can do
it I do it here every [__] day every
[__] day
why do you think I call them the real
America First Nazi party
why do you think I do that why do you
think I call Donald Trump Grandpa
Poopypants are the Cheeto dust q and
honor why do you think I do that
huh
why do you think I do that why do you
think I frame this up why do you think
when I go into the Twitter spaces I call
them I say that the uh the protesters in
Wadsworth Ohio that were protesting a
drag show I call them Republican Nazis
not just Nazis they're Republican Nazis
this is all messaging folks
yeah am I being transparent they're not
transparent about it right they're like
oh that's not what we're doing
we're not doing that we're not trying to
we're not trying to confuse people
that's just no that's what you're doing
[__]
and I'm here to be transparent about it
I'm here to be transparent
about the messaging yeah am I kind of
the circus clown on the left sure
whatever whatever you need me to be I'll
be that
because I believe I believe
that if the Democrats can make space for
messaging they can make space for it
because they don't make enough [__]
space right that's that was the problem
with the build back better Bill the BBB
I said if you call it the Big Bird Bill
and just call it an education Bill oh my
God that would have left so much space
for messaging
oh my god there would have been so much
more space for messaging the reason why
is because they had the infrastructure
built that was the messaging on that and
then they tried to re message this one
on that on top of that one too we're
gonna do two of them why are you doing
to them just do one infrastructure build
one education bill it wasn't complicated
it wasn't [__] everyone could see
that this would have worked
if they just would have called me that's
all they got to do is just pick up the
phone
call the guy that shows up on Thursday
wasted on his um His Radio his
International
radio show someone knows what I'm
talking about out there
oh
and I could have told them
but this is what they do and Jamal
Bowman
is not only correct in his thought
process but he's correct in his delivery
he's loud he does not give a [__] in
that moment and the reason why is
because the Dude
was a teacher and a principal
of a middle school when you think about
this
if you've had someone in your life that
you care about that you I mean think
about Jamal Bowman he's probably watched
his students grow up and become very
functional great adults they probably
done great things and he watched he he
watched them do that he got to be a part
of that by being an educator that's
that's I mean I'm not an educator but
that's probably one of the biggest Joys
that you could have as an educator
is seeing someone you taught
how to read someone you taught how to do
algebra someone someone that maybe you
even disciplined as the principal of a
middle school grow up and become a
highly functional adult successful adult
happy adult a functioning member of
society
a good person a good decent person with
empathy
that is probably one of the most
rewarding things I would imagine it
would be to be an educator
and then
to to
watch the news over and over and over
and time and time again
that these children are cut down
that they're ripped apart by by weapons
because we allow that to happen
because we allow these weapons to be
sold to anyone and everyone
we do we're the government we are the
[__] government
stop stop blaming stop blaming the
politicians It Is Us
we elect these [__]
jabal Bowman has the exact right cause
and his exact right delivery get [__]
loud
get [__] loud because it's not just
it's not just the gun issue
they're coming after your [__] health
care they're coming after your consent
of your children
the Nazis are at the door and they're
banging
we're trying to hold it closed
but it ain't gonna last too long
everyone stick around
I'll try to be back
no I'll be back right after this break
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
we're gonna watch a [__] ton of video
here and they last part of the show
we'll be right back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
wait was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we have plenty of lamb gems skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
here's Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
[__] a buckle [__] em [__] em [__] em
[__] em we're back to the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show
three I'm gonna show you this video of
the Jamal Lop Homan
given what more to Thomas Manson and I
want to thank you for being here
uh every single weekday even on the
weekdays where I am
may or may not be a bit hungover
I don't miss a day have you guys ever
seen me miss a day I mean I I we've
taken a few days off around the holidays
but I I don't miss a day for anything I
I would not miss this for the world that
is for sure I love being here with you
every single weekday two hours a day and
I I love the patreon thing
it's it's beginning to um
be a second home for me over there on
patreon if you guys are interested in
extra content we we what I do over there
is I give you a
early access to the social media clips
that I put out
of the show uh they're kind of cool I
have someone who does those for me that
that's all they do is produce those
clips
um for for me and other shows but they
they do a great job at the subtitles The
Sound the zooming it's it's all very
good so if you want early access to
those
um go to
patreon.commichaels and we got the
Sunday rant and next week we are going
to do once I get out of this fog today
I'm gonna set a date next week so
sometime next week we are going uh to do
the patreon party
and I'll probably just get drunk with
you right probably not as strong as I
was last night but I'll I'll we'll do a
little drinking maybe we'll uh watch
some watch some stuff that's not
politics we'll talk about stuff that's
politics or not politics in the party
and we'll just hang out together
um it won't be like you're a broadcast
it'll actually be more of a zoom type
meeting
um so go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels we're going to do the patreon
party next week and I'm going to open it
up to everyone the first one is going to
be open to everyone because I'm still
trying to figure this [__] out too you
know what I mean so and we're
experimenting experimenting I think uh
Gabe Sanchez may join us here soon but I
want to go to this uh before we
um get too deep and I want to show you
this video
of Jamal Bowman and you're gonna watch a
bunch of Republicans
um walking past Jamal Bowman here it's
just outside of it's just it's just
outside a house chamber right
um and he's talking about gun violence
and he's not talking
he's being loud about it
as he should be he's [__] pissed
Jamal Bowman is [__] pissed that
Republicans refuse to do anything and
this you know if you're listening to
someone out there and they're saying
some [__] like ow Democrats too get the
[__] out of here with that [__]
you you are full of [__] [__] if you
think this is not one party styming any
kind of gun or safety reform that we
could have
either at a state level or a federal
level that is all [__] [__]
the Democratic party is ready to pass
almost any kind I mean they would do the
assault weapons ban and and the
president of the United States would
sign it immediately
immediately and and they would do
temporary or a permanent ban which I
think it should be a permanent ban but I
I almost guaran damned to you that
Democrats would settle for a 10-year
temporary ban on assault weapons
and Joe Biden would sign that [__] as
they should
now you know a lot of people will say oh
Landing up far enough
well [__] you
far enough
we can't we can't even get these son of
a [__] to admit that there is a
problem Jesus Christ have you seen this
Andy um Ogle or whatever the [__] his
name is the one who posted the picture
of his of his [__] kids online having
guns and [__]
well it's my exercising and my second
amendment
yeah it is it is exercising your second
amendment and you're showing your
[__] stupidity
thank you for showing us that but this
person should not be in charge of
setting policy on anything I don't give
a not even just [__] guns
on anything
we don't have to put up with this [__]
anymore we just don't we don't have to
do it and Jamal Bowman does an excellent
job at saying and showing you that we do
not have to put up with this [__]
[__] listen listen to this clip
listen to him outside the house chamber
forced them to respond to the question
why the hell won't you do anything to
save America's children and let them
explain that all the way up until
election day of 2024.
let them explain it all the way up to
election day on 2024. they have freaking
Powers they're gutless they're not here
I'm talking about Gun Guys
support that more guns lead to more
deaths look at the data you're not
looking at any data
look at the day like four guys
[Music]
laws have more than that in every school
states that have open carrying laws
are dying
calm down you [__] man that's
like when they tell me to oh settle down
you man you really gotta take the heat
down on this oh man you're getting kind
of crazy on your show Tony you're really
you're really amping it up yeah you
goddamn right
[__] pissed
why shouldn't we be pissed now I wanna I
wanna show you on something here in this
Frame you see this [__] little coward
here
now you had the balls to stop and at
least um try to trying to talk to uh
representative Bowman here this is
Thomas Massey
this is another [__] scumbag that had
his kids on a Christmas card with with
the [__] guns
another one of these scumbags
I mean Jesus Christ they they're such
sycophants
to White gun culture in the gun lobby
that they're even putting they're
promoting
these stupid [__] policies around
guns on their Christmas cards
it's [__] crazy and ridiculous
and then he tells he tells Bowman to
calm down get the [__] out of here man
kids are dying the other the other thing
I want to show you here is um and I'm
gonna mute it while we're watching it
here
um you'll see you'll see when Thomas
Massey
stops to start talking to him this is
the the beginning of the exchange
and and they're they're going at each
other this right here is steny Hoyer
okay he's in leadership Democratic party
right
now
he thinks steady Warrior thinks he's
gonna stop Bowman from engaging like
this right and Bowen he doesn't he
doesn't even really acknowledge that
that
that leadership is standing there like
hey man hey man cut it out he's like
[__] you this these cowards are cowards
at least this one coward stopped the
dock to me even though he's saying the
most cowardly things right
the Absurd cowardly things about these
issues like oh we should put more guns
in the hands of teachers this guy was a
[__] teacher I'm gonna show you that
here in a minute Howie how he questions
him but you see you'll see stinny Hoyer
here
he's really trying to he's really trying
to like come on come on and then he's
like
well this ain't gonna work this ain't
gonna work
this ain't gonna nope nope ah okay I'm
done he just gives up he's like [__]
this [__] [__] this [__] I'm not even
gonna he just keeps on going I mean at
least and he gave it his best shot right
I mean maybe maybe not
I don't know okay so let's let's
continue watching uh Bowman because the
point where Bowman actually asked Thomas
Massey a question here is the part that
I want you to see
[Music]
okay okay
I'll bring it down a notch you go [__]
yourself that's what I took that is
um so I want to applaud uh
representative Bowman for speaking up
for speaking up for all the children in
this country uh who every day go to a
school and are terrified that someone
could bring in a weapon of war and rip
apart their teachers and rip apart their
classmates
um so [__]
I'm sick and tired of this [__] right I
told you the other day that I have a
daughter that is the exact same age as
three children that were killed in that
Christian school in Nashville
and [__] that that [__] with your head
that you send your children to school to
learn how to read
to learn to learn critical thinking
skills
to give them the tools that they need to
be functioning
members of society
we built an entire infrastructure around
this
to make sure our country is [__]
educated even as broken as the education
system may be
because I'll admit that
you know I you know my argument that I
don't believe that the education system
is up to par
as it should be right now
that shows just just go watch footage of
any [__]
cubanon Trump Nazi rally and you'll know
what the [__] I'm talking about
people know less about our democracy and
civics
then they know about [__] basic math
basic math and basic Civic should be
hand in hand
and we are failing people
but we can't even keep them safe
you [__] we can't even keep
Kids Safe not only that we can't [__]
you can't go to the grocery store you
can't go to a Goddamn parade you can't
go to church you can't go anywhere in
this country without worrying about
someone [__] mowing you down with a
goddamn semi-automatic weapon of War
and I give a [__] what you two-way Bros
say oh it's not this and it's not bad
and it's not this shut the [__] up
everyone knows exactly what those
weapons are and what they're for dummy
we're not [__] we're not that dumb
I mean we're not smart enough to [__]
do anything about it but we're not that
dumb to not know what the [__] they're
for okay we get it that's the reason why
they're used the way they're used and
what they're used for it's the reason
why they're manufactured you [__]
horse's ass
and Jamal Bowman here when he's making
these statements he's yelling these
statements rightfully so
not just not just representative Bowman
every [__] needs to be loud and
proud about these issues
it's what we have to do
and yes I'm telling you in 20 30 years
from now in this generation that's being
terrorized by the gun lobby and gun
manufacturers
grow up and they got children and they
inherit the country and they start to
take power in places they're not going
to put up with your stupid gun [__]
they're just not gonna do it
they're not going to
so either [__] [__] or get off the
pot you want your guns or you don't want
them because I'm I I'm of a generation
that has plenty plenty of guns in it
prior
to the assault weapons ban and the
assault weapons ban being taken off
is when the assault weapons ban was
removed they didn't renew it
I graduated high school in 2003 20 years
ago
I lived through school with the assault
weapons ban on we didn't [__] hand
Mass shooter drills wonder why hmm
I wonder why that is
we we did [__] fire drills
we did [__] drills for tornadoes
I live in Missouri just playing
tornadoes here
[__] we did earthquake drills
folks that's right in Missouri there's a
fault line we did earthquake drills in
Missouri
you [__] [__] me
that's the fear that we had when I was a
kid we were scared of [__] like
tornadoes and fires and earthquakes
not [__] guns it's the gun dumb
[__]
and Bowman's right
question him
not you and I and I think he could go
further than what he did we don't just
question now until 2024 we continue to
question them and continue to question
them and continue to push them
until not only do we ban assault weapons
but we get these [__] guns off our
goddamn streets for crying the [__] out
loud
and I I'm I'm calling on you if you're a
liberal out there and you own a gun one
of these guns go [__] turn it in go
go do a gun buyback on that son of a
[__] [__] that piece of [__] you don't
need that [__]
it might be fun it might be cool but
just think about if that gun somehow
Works its way in the hands that will
kill someone you love
it's not [__] worth it I'm telling
you it's not it's not [__] worth it
it's not
get rid of that [__] [__] that [__] you
don't need that [__] we don't need those
[__]
we got plenty of Plenty where that came
from anyways
we got Gabe Sanchez with us about
goddamn time huh man
I
I'm a little uh right there did you
watch this video with the Jamal I'm uh
I'm I'm uh I haven't what was that
coming out oh okay good good yeah yeah
it's kind of crazy the one of the one of
the best parts is at the end when he's
asking before he says oh you want me to
calm down you want me to [__] God yeah
the idea that he's like oh you want me
to calm down like that like look at the
end of the day like somebody responding
the way that he responded is totally
natural right right he's like oh you
want me to calm down no like being upset
being frustrated being sad being angry
being pissed off
those are those are those are totally
normal things to respond but he's like
oh calm down it's like don't [__]
Gaslight me and tell me to calm down you
little [__] I was a school teacher a
principal you've never walked into
school and you're trying to tell me that
giving teachers guns is the is right is
the actual uh
uh solution here no [__] that [__] you
guys are willing to take away all sorts
of uh
uh school supplies and you're not
willing to pay me the salary I should be
paid and you're trying to ban books and
as a solution you say you know what we
should give you a [__] nine
millimeter [__] that [__] right
it's [__] I mean and at the end when
he's asking him have you ever have you
ever have you ever worked at a school
like yeah I've worked at a school
[__] like my expertise is just
not on me out here yelling and screaming
that you're cowards like my expertise is
[__] education dummy yeah
the table he's like I have first-hand
experience I know what it's like to run
a school I know what it's like to be in
the classroom I know what it's like to
facilitate a a safe learning environment
and unfortunately we live in a reality
right now where fire you know gun
violence is an everyday occurrence in
communities but also right because he
also there's another clip where he calls
it out and he's like look there are
crimes and gun violence that's happening
in brown and black communities and they
are doing absolute [__] they don't care
they don't even care when the children
are dead they control the house and we
need you to know right now
that they have the house and they are
unwilling
to help those dying children to help
prevent future deaths of children like
you would think a group that loves to
protect the children and loves to save
the children and loves Jesus Christ and
loves caring for Thy Neighbor you would
think that these people these
Republicans these Christian loving God
fear and Christians you think that these
people you you would you would you would
safely assume that based on the
principles that they project out into
the world right that they would actually
want to do
what they could do to prevent shootings
from happening
debts from happening right and then
Thomas Massey's like oh you know what we
got to give more guns we got to give
more guns because a good guy with the
gun stops a bad guy with the gun you
don't even have to look less than a year
ago in May of 2022 we had a school
shooting where 19 innocent children died
were slaughtered with an AR-15 and and
he has to say he has the goal to say
this pushing this [__] response
about open carry laws actually solve
problems open carry laws don't they
increase all homicides and all firearm
like there is no
it's so dumb and you know what's crazy I
was looking up Thomas Massey yesterday
because I was like what's Thomas
Massey's background do you know that he
went to MIT did you know that he like
are you [__] [__] me he went to
MIT he got a he uh he he ended up
winning a competition and did all this
other stuff like this guy is not an
idiot he's not an idiot oh I mean okay
look in terms if you were to if you were
to measure intelligence and be like oh
this guy went to MIT and he's right like
science competition and did this other
he also has a patent and had this uh
dissertation and this and that like he
knows what he's doing is what you're
saying the guy is not Marge Taylor green
or Lauren bober right oh we're gonna
show those clips holy [__] you talk
about some dumb [__] this this
guy is someone who who knows right from
wrong right right and he actively he
knows right from wrong and he he knows
what he can do to prevent this and what
does he do he chooses he chooses yes
like a useful idea it he actively
chooses to not lift a finger to help
stop these innocent children from dying
I mean if you want to say you know
adults like [__] it whatever I don't
really care about adults but again the
children our next Generation the ones
that they say that we need to love and
we need to care and we need to protect
for children
who can't fend for themselves right
exactly right save the children these
children are innocent they are
vulnerable they can't they can't go up
against an AR-15 I mean let alone an
adult right well you know we gotta give
them wait a second we gotta give them
bulletproof backpacks and bulletproof
lunch boxes we gotta bulletproof desk we
got to make sure that every every school
is a prison so no one can get in or out
I mean I mean that is you know that's
the world we live in right we've got the
we've got the white it shouldn't be
we've got the Whiteboard that goes from
the corner and then goes yeah like a
safe room yeah yeah exactly the fact
that we have to create bulletproof
backpacks and whiteboard safe rooms and
we have to go through these types of
exercises or the way that you did you do
you know how they re have rebranded like
the the active shooter drill
which I didn't know about until until
the the shooting just this past day in
National what do you think it's the it's
like it's called hide and seek or like
surprise or whatever [__] Jesus and
now it's a game and so now because I
mean I understand
the logic in the sense of
how do we not traumatize a kid even more
right yeah I I know how I I just you get
rid of the [__] possibility oh there
we go yeah right and so when they do
when they do these you know um I I'm
blanking on the name but I know so like
to the point Mighty librarian it's
called the lockdown drill but they have
a different name for the kids so they
call it this like they make it a game
where like okay be a good be a good girl
be a good boy and go hide and like make
sure no one can find you kind of thing
do you know the reason why teachers are
against
um carrying weapons the majority of them
and it's not that they're they're like
there's some you know libtard idiot that
doesn't know or doesn't want to have a
gun the reason why is because
because the teachers go through much
more extensive training and much more
traumatizing training on this active
shooter because in most cases in Most
states I believe now this is the case
here in Missouri a lot with these
because I have several [__] friends
that aren't teachers they're Educators
that's what they've done their entire
lives or their entire adult life once
again out of college
a lot of the training is that the
teachers are trained
to give their life
to protect children which I I would
expect almost any any reasonable adult
decent adult with empathy to do right
but none of that that's worked
but you're showing them they're training
them step in front of the bullets and
what's crazy is these these teachers are
like wait a second so not only do you
now expect ex expect me
to fight this person who has a gun now
you want me to
you want me to get a gun myself and fire
back and like have a gunfight you want
me to be a soldier like I'm I'm a
[__] teacher man I'm a teacher like
pencils erasers [__] Elmer's Glue
type [__] man not no [__] nine
millimeter what are you [__] out of
your mind I listen most teachers I
believe like most people aren't against
guns are gun ownership right or even the
Second Amendment but they're not they're
like I didn't [__] become a teacher
to get into a gun fight with somebody
okay yeah that's not why I became a
teacher and so the and they do this
several times a year like because this
is a refresher course and and um
we watched the video I didn't I'm not
going to show it on the show but um I
believe you sent it to me of the um the
killer the shooter in Nashville being
the law enforcement taking them out it
was man I mean law enforcement boy they
were Johnny on the spot with that body
cam footage weren't they I mean yeah
other body cam pictures like whoa whoa
no no we didn't murder a black dude they
they definitely don't want to give that
but when they [__] well you'd be
surprised what happens how quickly they
act when they're like oh it was a bunch
of black police officers that killed the
black right they're like oh yeah yeah we
killed that trans shooter right like you
didn't see those things in you Baldi you
didn't see those things in other places
they're very hesitant when it goes
against a long time right yeah but
here's the thing is that even in that
video
even in that video and I I text this
back to you because I thought it was
very I thought it was very intriguing
um from the one the the body Cam that
the guy's footage was he seemed like the
the leader of the you know this the
squad or whatever he was kind of giving
directions and how they were going to
the building but it felt like to me and
I told you this I said and and they were
Brave to go in there I mean we watched
the police officers from you've all the
[__] cowards wouldn't even go save
those children give their lives to save
those children these officers were brave
enough to go in but it felt like to me
that they didn't know exactly what was
right what to expect or what to do I
mean I mean it almost like they were
hesitating to some degree
um and I mean I I of course in that
situation you know when someone's got a
semi-automatic rifle or several of them
or several semi-automatic weapons and
possibly they got body armor on and
you're gonna go get in a gunfight with
them whether you're a police officer
teacher it's not something you want to
wake up in the morning and do right like
this is like ah hope I hope I have to
get in a gunfight today like that's not
something you're wishing for right even
if that's part of your [__] job to do
it
um but but it it felt like to me that
they were hesitant like they hadn't
trained for it or something or some of
the officers hadn't trained it felt like
the guy who's the body Cam and was
giving directions he'd been trained or
he at least had some idea of what he
wanted to do but the other officers not
that they weren't doing it or they
weren't Brave they just did it didn't
feel like in the video that they knew
the layout of the school were familiar
with it
um yeah trained for it but it's crazy
that we gotta we gotta have police
officers memorize the layout of a school
because it's very likely that someone's
gonna go in there with a gun and we're
gonna have to go gun them down in a
school like what in the [__] is wrong
with us I mean we live in a in a you
know and I'll even one-up you on on uh
on your teacher having to have a gun to
defend the classroom you know
we're seeing that in more and more of
these situations there are kids that are
coming back
to that school they once attended right
so the likelihood that a teacher would
have to confront or be the victim of
that student is very likely right there
is an increased possibility or
likelihood that would happen
now imagine you're a teacher who has a
gun and you have to look down the
[__]
hallway and kill one of your students
you're one of your former students well
I mean in the Parkland in the Parkland
shooting right he was a student at that
school so they were expecting teachers
to kill their students right
what the [__] are you I'm talking about
man it's it's insane for I mean it's
insane but also on brand that when you
have Republicans there's no solution
right they like we're gonna make we're
gonna [__] [__] on this problem we're
gonna complain about it or blame some
other non-issue and then on top of that
we're going to say uh you know what we
actually don't care anymore look we
can't stop it I know that we created it
but it's like we yeah it is what it is
just move on already like that's the
part of the world that's the Republican
party it is so much like when we
yesterday we played the clip of uh
representative bird [__] from Tennessee
right who has the luxury of
homeschooling his daughter because he
knows that's the safest place he can
have his daughter because he knows that
our gun laws and our accessibility to
guns and the gun violence we have
because of those things
makes her a victim or a Target at a
school so he says you know what for most
of the time I can control I'm going to
keep you in the house and we're going to
make sure you stay in this house until
you're 18. and then after that
if you want to stay home and go to
Community College hey that just even
better or did the grocery store or a
movie theater or a [__] parade you're
on your own sis uh Province the supply
brings up how about we just give
teachers hand grenades I think Bazookas
too why not yeah
they uh from what I understand the
bigger the gun the right the more
deterrent it is right it's the safer it
is the safer and the more again so maybe
we should give them like uh you know
just like cases of grenades not just one
yeah no we should give them a whole
arsenal of the whole weapons listen the
more Firepower you got the safer it is
from Firepower it's you know what we
should do is you know for the schools
that have basements we should totally
convert those into armories right and
then have that as a spot where you can
just like willy-nilly walk in and be
like cool I'm getting this gun and maybe
I check it out maybe I don't in terms of
signing the paperwork you know he's
going down and get the splice you know
what's funny about this province of
supplies uh
this statement here
I'm just thinking about it like if you
if you actually presented this idea to
Republicans they'd be like hmm you know
that's not like are you [__] kidding
so we got to be careful really
it's you have to remember too that like
in Sasha Baron co uh Sasha bear Cohen's
uh show who is America he actually has a
conversation with one of these I forget
exactly their position but he has a
conversation with a republican you know
uh legislator and and says hey you know
what we need to do and I think he went
in as like uh in his like he he was set
up as an Israeli uh Soldier and he's
like I you know he's like I have
experience of all the stuff and like one
program that we had in Israel is that we
gave kindergarters AK-47s and did all
the stuff right and then the guy was
like that's actually not a bad idea you
know and he was and like you watch it
and you're like what though what [__]
[__] like we I think he had something
like Pre-K like pre AK-47 or something
like that he he made but he was talking
about as a joke right but also to call
out these crazy crazy ideas that
Republicans have they don't even think
about like I just still a gun in the
solution why not that'll fix it and he
goes oh you know what that's actually a
pretty good idea and you're watching and
you're like what the [__] well that's
the white gun culture that I I've been
talking about and I talked about in the
first 30 minutes is if you got a problem
in white gun culture a gun will fix it
like no matter what the problem it
doesn't matter what the problem is
it doesn't matter a gun will fix it for
whatever reason it it's almost like if
you got a problem blame it on wokism and
I mean I don't know what they do yeah
then a gun away Tony but you know what I
just thought of yeah
why can you bring a gun into school but
you can't bring a gun
to a trump Rally or an NRA convention
it's almost like that they're dangerous
I'm just you know whoa maybe you're
you're telling me that the Republicans
know that a gun is violent and then yes
that maybe their base might be more
prone to violence or they might be more
prone to mishandling or misusing a gun
and causing accidental gun violence
that's what I'm saying yeah oh wow well
let me show it to you here this is um
the Tennessee holler is so good at this
he is so [__] good at this now this
is nine minutes I can't even believe he
has nine minutes of footage of this yeah
so what he did the other day after this
happened in Nashville he went to the
Capitol to question the state
representatives there
um to ask them what they were going to
do about this after the shooting now
again there's nine [__] minutes of
this I'm not gonna play all nine of it
there's nine nine minutes of this [__]
yeah I'm surprised that they even like
uh humored him for that long oh well
well I mean it's it's clips of he
approaches so many of them just watch
this this is great
today kids died yesterday what are you
doing today Iris
anything about gun violence the number
one killer of kids you should look at
your watch who doesn't have time anymore
Jay
about gun violence today I think should
that be the number
should be the number one thing on all of
our months
exactly fortunately I passed a bill a
few weeks ago that would allow private
schools to partner with global law
enforcement hopefully that school will
take
people that could then shoot there was
no weapons of war and you know that
there's no weapons of war that was not
alone
what good does it do Jeremy to have
assault weapons in the hands of the
hands of anybody who wants whatever form
are you are you proposing you seem like
you've got something I've done the
background check every time I bought a
gun
check to get money but I don't have time
in the hands of anybody who wants one
AR-15s are what keep getting used to
kill trolls why would anybody need one
I've heard a good reason can you guys
maybe ask him probably some others in
here why do they need one
doing anything about gun violence today
limiting weapons of war so that they
can't shoot kids with them who is they
who are you talking about whoever wants
one I find your question pleasantly
vague perhaps you'd like to sharpen it
sure let's sharpen it what are you
willing to do about gun violence the
number one killer of children gun
violence is a non-specific term you love
to do that you love to get into the
semantics of stuff I'm asking you a
straightforward question no you're not
it's going to look ridiculous
Divine gun violence when kids die at the
hands of powerful weapons that have no
business being on the street I disagree
with you sir what do you disagree with
me about every thing yeah exactly so
what are we doing about gun violence
today man I'll talk to you
what are we doing to keep Kids Safe
anything
three kids died yesterday do you want
anything today
you're not wearing your Confederate flag
time today what are we doing
kids you're a family man right Joey yeah
yeah all your kids are just so many kids
Joey the kids died yesterday who
supported any gun safety legislation
I actually have a gun safety bill that I
get for gun safety classes for everybody
classes
AP legislation I I have not been
involved in any of that disease
I don't think that is allowed right now
yes it is actually you don't think
that's allowed you don't think people
can buy assault weapons what state do
you live in you don't know the laws in
your own state that person bought those
legally yesterday I've not heard all the
reports from all that so I'm not sure
enough to even read the reports Michelle
they've known All of Me Now kids died
and you don't even read the reports you
don't know that assault weapons are
legal in Tennessee and you're a lawmaker
Vincent talk to her man I know you're a
big pro-gun guy but yeah anything you're
willing to support the limit young in
the streets as far as what as far as
assault weapons
they don't exist assault yeah talk this
is your thing right you're just leaving
background checks there's red flag laws
there's limiting high capacity magazines
staring at that button isn't going to
make it go any faster
oh God
kids died does he support anything it's
been terrible man yeah
it is the right time to talk about it
actually it's exactly the right time to
talk about it because it makes you
uncomfortable because you won't do
anything about it
hey Monty Hey sir you still think
there's no such thing as gun violence
What's Your Name by the way what's your
name would you go to school is there
such thing as would you go to school
Jeff I'm asking the questions here man
you're just a hippie you're just a
hippie with a cell phone a hippie oh
you're one of those guys huh a hippie
with a cell phone he called me anything
happened yesterday that moved you if you
want to do anything about gunpowitz the
number one killer of kids dog anything
maybe you guys could ask her in this
elevator what she's doing to keep kids
safe from God
I I could do that all day long oh my God
I I really could watch the whole nine
minutes you should go watch the whole
nine minutes it's [__] incredible
it's [__] incredible and it's just
he's not he's not having to like come up
with any kind of intellectual arguments
he's just asking state representatives
who are elected to keep to do their job
to set policy to keep public schools and
schools in the state of Tennessee safe
and the [__] get in elevators
and run away from him because he asked
what are you doing to protect children
and they're running from those questions
nothing the answer is nothing they won't
do anything right they're running
they're uncomfortable they know that
again they know they're wrong they know
right from wrong right and that's why
that's why they're embarrassed right
yeah yeah I mean like it is the right
time you should be doing exactly what
he's doing you should be exactly what
Jamal Bowman's doing you should be doing
the constant calling out and being like
what are you doing to because the
question is what are you doing to stop
children from dying of gun violence
right it's not like what are you doing
to stop gun violence what are you doing
to stop children from dying by the hands
of guns
and Republicans don't want to answer
that question because they know that we
know that they're in the pocket of the
NRA and they're beholden to the NRA and
they're unwilling if you were to go to
open Secrets right now the website
opensecrets.org I think it is and you
were to look up the NRA and you want to
look at the breakdown of party donations
it's very impressive to see that it's
100 donations
Red Bar on open Secrets that show you
that NRA money does not go into a blue
group it goes only into red so when you
look at it says zero percent Democrats
Republicans because they know
that they are easily bought
they know
that Republicans don't have ethics or
morals or any sort of uh they know
they're cowards right exactly they're
gutless cowards who are again beholden
to the NRA and unwilling to do anything
right to save a child's life and that is
disgusting unacceptable and completely
avoidable gun violence is avoidable it
is something that can be prevented
especially in a school with an automatic
rifle or a semi-automatic rifle or an
assault weapon whatever it might be
it is preventable we can avoid it there
can be things done I mean [__] man we
can use the 1996 assault weapons ban in
Australia it took one [__] shooting
it took one shooting in Scotland it took
one in England
they're not [__] idiots have you ever
heard of lawn darts like the the the
original lawn darts do you know what
they are
um
lawn darts they're like they're like a
big huge [__] Dart like you know
dartboard yeah yeah [__] Dart and
they were metal darts right and you
threw them in the yard and they'd stick
in the ground right oh that sounds
dangerous right so they they
manufactured these things and they
became really popular there was three
children killed by these [__] lawn
darts do you know why you don't know
what londars are they [__] banned
them whoa they [__] look at that fandom
because three kids were killed wait wait
but are you but what about our lawn dart
lobbyists
lobbyists come in and and try to put
money in their pocket so they would vote
against it listen I I understand where
you're going with this that you're
saying that the lawn Lobby should be
much bigger uh than it really truly is
and they should definitely be making
donations uh and and lobbying and and
not just uh the federal house but the
state house to make sure that our kids
can be killed by lawn darts like that is
there you know god-given right it's it's
like the 36th Amendment or something to
our to our constitution or some [__] but
let's
but the reason why you don't know what
londards are is because they were
[__] banned they banned those
[__] because they were
dangerous as [__] they were dangerous as
a [__] people getting hurt and
killed and three kids got killed by them
and they're like we can't do this [__]
what are we what are we doing letting
these people sell these [__] these
big ass hunks of metal that's gonna you
know impale some child and kill them
they're like we can't hand that [__] so
they're like yeah we're gonna ban those
boom band yeah I mean they're quick to
ban other things man they are quick to
ban when when you see other other uh
other products that like oh it's a
choking hazard gotta ban it it's this
gotta ban it a gun well do we really
need to ban it guys do we and it's like
yes the answer is yes if you've got a
gun
that would they honestly
that is stroke as [__] I mean we live in
a world where lawn darts are more
dangerous than guns according according
to our legislators well Bobby says
where's the picnic Lobby man dude I'm
looking for him I've got I put my pin
down where I'm have my my picnic at and
they're not showing up you know
Billy Billy boy says I love the Honduras
like dangerous horseshoes
Parts aren't fun lawn darts is really
fun yeah one of the fun things is you
may get to impale someone and go to the
ER and take videos it's really anyone's
Game Dude right you know right if you
die well I guess I won the game huh it's
a decent it's a decent like um cover if
you want to you know you know off
somebody right yeah the same right the
same way I'm saying that that like
guns
semi-automatic weapons when you go like
a firing range and you're shooting them
and you know there's you get this
adrenaline rush and it's the pow pow pow
pow pow the the percussion of the
[__] gun yeah the kickback you can
feel the power in your hand I mean the
ultimate power that you're carrying to
mow down dozens of humans in a matter of
seconds like I'm not saying that that
doesn't have this Allure to it right
like it's not like oh my God this is so
[__] awesome I mean if you've ever
watched like a Gatling gun like a video
of a Gatling gun how [__] fun would
it be to [__] shoot one of those I'm
not saying that it's it's not fun lawn
darts is [__] fun yeah cool that's
it's kind of a cool thing
but it's not something that has to be
done right it just we don't have to have
that you can do other fun things like
drink a whole bottle of Jager on
Wednesday night and I mean you could do
those things for sure I mean I also also
I'm pretty I don't know man uh you're
talking about another industry that's
kind of regulated you know what's that
the alcohol industry oh well yeah yeah
you know oh you got to be 21 to have it
you can't go out you can't even go
outside the doorway right right so here
in Missouri a liquor license you can't
leave the bar
you can't leave the bar now they have um
patios right so like even even at
restaurants that serve alcohol if
they've got a patio they have to have a
locked fence around the patio because
then you're not leaving leaving the bar
you're not in public anymore and then
certain events like certain events
outside where there's beer like uh like
a the you can have a beer garden but
again it has to be it has to have a
perimeter
um but there's some places that have
events that aren't have a perimeter but
they have to have a special license to
have people walking around in those
areas with alcohol like oh this is
[__] dangerous we can't just have
people walking around with a beer in
their hand like as if that's a [__]
danger to everyone else around them yeah
we know we know the dangers of alcohol
we know it trust me I I know it
firsthand today I'm getting better here
I think you're probably in that period
of like before The Hangover comes you
know where you get like you wake up and
you're like uh and like maybe I was
drunk when I woke up yeah yeah and I
think right now what's happening is
you're beginning to taper off and right
you're gonna hit a point where you go oh
[__] man like you're gonna hit a wall
afterwards when this show is done I'm
I'm here's what I'm gonna do when this
show is done I'm gonna make the audio
edit I'm probably gonna take a big huge
[__] and then I'm gonna take a long
[__] nap it's probably what I'm gonna
do and it's probably not gonna get much
get done that's this afternoon totally
totally fine I'm just saying I mean a
lot of people say too much information
but that's just what's gonna happen a
lot of people want to know what the
Tennessee holler is and you really
should go follow the tennis yeah
um at the Tennessee holler on Twitter
and you can go to TN holler that's
t-n-h-o-l-l-e-r.com
tendencyholler.com just Google it too
Tennessee holler and you'll find them we
need to get just I actually uh messaged
Justin Justin said he'd come on the show
uh Justin is the one that is in the
video
that we just watched where he's
questioning lawmakers he's the one that
generally is at the state capitol there
uh questioning uh these [__] scumbags
about their stupid [__] policies the
ones they know they're intentionally
what what the intention of it is or lack
of attention that there is but um but uh
Justin uh I I messaged him we really
should get him on the show and talk to
him about um his strategy down there
because I I know uh I'd love to talk to
him about all the crazy [__] that goes
on down there but I mean we only got two
hours so I mean I couldn't I couldn't I
couldn't talk to him uh for that long
but
um what we should do is approach it kind
of like we do with uh Dr Rachel
bidikoffers say hey what's the um
um what's the what's the
what's the strategy that you use when
you're when you question these people
what what are you doing right that
normal people can do when they see
someone and how they question them
um because he obviously does a great job
of it he makes that yeah I think you
know for the in the same way that Walter
does it or right uh or he does it or the
good liars or the good liars like
there's
there's definitely the way which like
hey look I'm gonna make I'm just gonna
because I think there's a there's a few
different approaches one is you're very
direct like Tennessee Hall you're like
look what do you guys like simple
questions but what are you doing and
then when they you know don't say
anything or they are unwilling to
to uh actually do something about it
then you call them out
there's the ten uh there's the the good
liars approach which is I'm just gonna
interview you and I'm gonna ask you
questions I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
State what my political stance is I'm
just gonna interview you and I'm going
to ask questions back based on what you
said not in an aggressive way or not in
your face way and I'm going to expose
the hypocrisy or the projection uh that
you hold uh as someone within the
Republican party and then there's Walter
Walter just goes out [__] clowns
people in the street which is great
right and some people believe it he also
has the good liars approach will ask
questions as like undercover right
because Walter has a different a couple
different approaches yeah yeah and he
really likes the one and the reason why
Walter does the clowning is because it
gets a lot of attention yeah like when
he does those clowning videos it gets
tons of views so he's trying because
what Walter's trying to do is not just
clown him he's trying to bring attention
to how ridiculous they are right and he
did it the other day outside the
Manhattan maybe I'll show that before it
goes I've got a good liars video here
speaking of
[Music]
at its finest
uh and you know
um we were watching then we'll talk
about this AdWords which do you think
are more dangerous uh drag shows or guns
to children
how many people do you think have been
killed at a drag show
uh
I don't know but the long-term effects
are detrimental how many people do you
think die every year from guns I have no
idea forty eight thousand forty eight
thousand okay well there's probably a
hundred thousand buy from die from drag
shows which you think oh my God okay I
want to point something out here and I
I'm I you know me do what you do I don't
give a damn you're free to be who you
want and dress how you want
um
is this a dude I'm just wondering is
this a dude I think it's a dude are you
sure I don't know
I mean oh here look I don't know it's a
person I know but what I'm saying is is
this this person is holding a it's got a
purse yeah
I'm just I mean is that a purse it I
mean no it's a bottle of water no oh oh
oh oh I see it's like the help the [__]
you say like a little sad sorry sorry
sorry it's like Indiana Jones then yeah
is that what this is yeah it's immerse
it's immerse I mean again I I'm not
against a dude having a purse I don't
give a [__] fanny pack purse backpack
whatever you want I don't give a [__] if
you want to dress up in a dress sing and
dance and entertain people I don't give
a [__] yeah
but the other thing that's pretty
significant here is I think this
person's hair has died
I'm just saying now this is a person
who's against drag shows and the reason
why they're against drag shows is
because they bought the [__] line
that
drag queens are are transgender people
which is not that's if you [__]
people got your heads Twisted okay trans
people can be drag queens yeah right
anyone could be a drag queen if you want
to be but the drag queens aren't
transgender people okay you're getting
it [__] confused someone who puts a
dress on isn't necessarily transgender
but here this guy is got his hair dyed
he's got his Ultra Mega shirt on he's
holding a bottle of water like it's a
baby and he's got a person and he's
standing there saying a hundred thousand
a hundred thousand people died
from a drag show what the [__] listen he
doesn't believe that he doesn't believe
the people he doesn't believe this
there's no one think you don't think
that this person believes this no you
don't think that they looked at
themselves and they said look a little
forty eight thousand if the real threat
in America is drag shows and people in
drag shows die or people die in drag
shows and if 48 000 people die from gun
violence well then clearly
um
two times that has to be the answer
I mean I believe that they believe that
as much as I believe that this person
that I'm going to show you now
has a brain
did you did you see this video
there's children dying in this country
from Guns is this about the urine
Lauren bobert is really highly focused
on someone pulling their pecker out in
public it's almost like there's a reason
maybe she's obsessed with this I don't
know it's probably projection I hear
that uh her husband uh has been accused
charged of crimes for getting his
whacker out in the bowling alley did you
know that did you know I did I did and
you know what's great like he did it to
her and to other underage girls and then
Lauren bobert was like I'm gonna marry
that man
so I'm gonna marry that man he's gonna
be my husband so what you're saying is
he got his tally wanker out showed
showed her his tallywacker and a couple
other teenagers in the bowling alley and
she snagged him
yeah she was like oh that is a man I'm
always gonna be proud of like she she
saw him she saw his dick and was like I
can make some babies out of that I went
in and then she was like and then when
my baby has has he gets to the rough age
of 17 he's gonna have himself a baby
that is Lauren Boberg and that and
Lauren allegedly allegedly the girl that
his or is the uh that occur son who's 17
he turns 18 this month
yeah or next month or something like
that
allegedly
I don't know if this is true but the
girl that he got pregnant is like 15 or
16. yeah which I mean is right in the
Wheelhouse for these Republicans you
know but Lauren bobert she sees someone
commit a crime like
expose himself to other people and she
goes hmm that's my man how old what's
her husband's name isn't it some dumb
[__] I don't know dude I don't [__]
carry his name it's something dumb and
here's the thing all of the the only
people's names that I know are the
representatives that say stupid [__]
like Lauren bobert or Margaret Taylor
green right or [__] representative
bird [__] which is his real name and not
that's it or whatever
and and when you
when people go what's their what's their
spouse's name what's their I don't
[__] care because those spouses are
[__] idiots wait AJ on on face yes
it's Jason with a Y is it really no
[__] way no [__] way yeah are you
serious yeah oh my God how old was Jason
when he got his little [__] pecker
out and showed a bunch of teenage girls
with Jason bobert uh spell it right it's
with it I know I know why I've done so
much effort to forget his name and as
soon as I saw that I was like God damn
it it is Jason
in 2004 is when he
showed it uh he was 24. and then so wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait there's a
24 year old dude standing in a bowling
alley yeah and in the middle of the
bowling alley and maybe he maybe he was
right about Lauren maybe he was right
he's like I'm gonna get my dick out and
she's totally gonna marry me like I mean
it's gonna work why do dudes think that
you can just get your dick out in front
of a bunch of people and be like well
this is gonna impress him like what the
[__] it's it's uh what I think
uh uh hold on
there's a um
is there a name for this is that what
you're about to tell me no I was just
gonna say in California I was gonna say
in California we have a new law that was
passed in 2022 which is The Flash the
4-bit lewd activity and sexual
harassment act that allows people to sue
up to thirty thousand dollars for cyber
flashing AKA sending someone oh like a
dick pic yep exactly so Jason Jason
bobert 24 goes to a bowling alley and
says
and shows it and then Lauren bobert says
ooh who's 17 by the way okay she's not
18. so she was 17. 17 and she saw that
dick and said
it'll do
she was like it'll do she saw that dick
and was like I'm gonna make some babies
she saw that dick and said you know what
a real man is a real man is someone who
exposes himself
with no silly like he just came out was
like Hey gay you want to see a magic
trick and then whipped out his dick and
then
he probably I would assume yeah
Jason bobert with a y
was at the bowling alley and he's like
want to see a magic trick and whipped
out his dick and had a bowling ball in
his hand and was like look what I could
do and then he was gonna do it and then
people were like oh my God this you know
some people might have been like uh
I'm just surprised that nobody like you
know tackled this guy or
punched him or whatever but this guy
this guy Jason her husband by the way
the rap sheet between Jason bobert and
Lauren bobert just go Google it anyone
who's watched the show just go [__]
Google the rap sheet of the crimes
they've done the the the fines they've
been given and the times in court that
they haven't shown up
so but Lauren bobert is an idiot and the
idea that she saw dick and was like yeah
you don't think that she saw that dick
and was like oh man you know what he's a
boy now but I'm gonna make him a man
even though he's 24. here's what I want
to tell you here's what I want to tell
you I would bet he got his dick out and
she's like what's your name and he's
like Jason and she's like how do you
spell it and he's like with a wine I
don't even think that's dumb I don't
even I don't even think she asked how
you spell it he goes she goes oh what's
your the other two girls like what the
[__] and he and they left right and then
uh Jason was like uh see you're still
here and Lauren bobert's Like You Bet
Your Sweet Dick I am and then he goes
you want to get a beer and throw some
balls down and then she goes what's your
name and he goes uh Jason with a y
and then she goes she goes oh you better
put some babies in me tonight oh my God
that is how Lauren bobert and Jason
bobert [__] became the bobert I'm
pretty sure she had she had her kid when
she was 19. so they probably waited a
couple years right you know because
maybe they knew like oh you know what we
can't get you pregnant now you mean
after the arrest and the charge and the
conviction yeah yeah after after they've
been arrested and been fine for
different things and this well after he
got arrested and charged with getting
his dick out yeah of course I mean it uh
you know what you gotta you gotta
remember that the uh the subtlety and
the um
um the way in which you treat women is
not uh is not something that is like
first of mine right the there you know
there's no chivalry to
uh to the Republican Party especially
men right they just think that you know
what I should do is I should expose
myself without you asking in a public
place where children are Tony because
children are some of the top clients or
customers that go to bowling alleys
birthday parties I just went to a
bowling alley this past weekend by the
way I just want to point this out it's
been like probably 10 11 years since I
went to a bowling alley but I was
watching TV show and I was talking to my
partner I was like hey did you get your
dick out did you get your dick out you
know I didn't I did not have to get my
dick making sure just making sure you
know I wasn't I wasn't surveying the
area looking for uh an Earthen vessel
we'll say
I went to the bowling alley and I said
hey look there's a birthday party and
there's a birthday party and there's a
bunch of kids and there's some teenagers
and there are some other people who are
like real Bowlers and I was with you
know wait wait wait what do you mean
they're being a sort of judgmental there
what do you mean real Bowlers like real
like it was like had the whole gear had
their bowling balls had sure it's like
Big Lebowski type [__] yes yeah they
they weren't [__] around right you
know they had the whole get up and they
seemed to be professional but as I went
through I would say a majority of the
clientele at this bowling alley were
kids or teenagers they were trying to
have fun so Jason bobert you know the
party of save the kids and you Democrats
are [__] groomers
these are the people that show up to a
kids party yeah or a kids environment a
teenagers like Lauren bobert and the
other two girls are and they and he goes
hey man this is what I'm gonna do today
like he woke up and was like I'm gonna
show my dick to some girls at a bowling
alley
and they think it's totally okay they
think let that go how'd that go what was
his thought again he woke up and he's
like I'm gonna show my dick to some
girls in a bowling alley that's what he
did because they're underage girls right
and the fact that the fact that these
people look at this and go there's not
something wrong with this dude and
there's not something wrong with this
woman that are part of our cult right
because of course they look and they go
hmm
here's the thing their son who's having
a baby is going to be talking well he's
not having to be you gotta he got it he
got an underage girl pregnant and
they're gonna have a baby right right
and Lauren bobert and Jason bobert are
gonna be grandparents and they are going
to have a conversation with that kid at
some point when they're older and he's
and and the boy or girl whoever they are
is gonna say hey can you tell me the
story about how you met grandma or how
you met Grandpa and then Jason or
Lauren's gonna be like well
it was a sunny day in Rifle Colorado and
I showed up to a bowling alley with my
girlfriends and I saw this guy with a
glimmer in his eye and a dick out of his
pants and that's when I knew he was
gonna be your grandpa or or she could
just say show him Grandpa sure
he's like he's like show me what you did
yeah and that's totally okay and then
Jason I'll show you my pickup move I'll
take you to the bowling lane where I
showed it and then they go back to the
bowling lane and they're like this is
what it is and then everyone there is
like hey there's nothing [__] weird
about this family no absolutely not well
you know I I I I I see your point about
how this may be how Jason with a Y
picked up Lauren without a brain okay I
I get that that's probably what maybe
how it happened but apparently
apparently Lauren bobert is now against
public exposure she's totally against
you not only is she totally against it
she still does not have a brain
later on right behind the curtain gonna
give her brain or is she just totally
lost well okay
I keep telling you this uh the audience
this time and time again the reason why
these members of Congress seem so
[__] stupid like Margaret Taylor
green Lauren bobert Jim Jordan Matt gatz
the reason why they do stupid [__] in
committee hearings when they're
questioning Witnesses the reason why
they make fools of themselves is because
their staffs are as dumb as they are
there's no real [__] serious stamper
in Washington that would work for these
[__] clowns and the reason why is
because if you'll work for one of these
clowns you're never going to be able to
work for someone serious yeah never you
you're not gonna want that reputation
that you worked with one of these clowns
especially after you see this clip
several weeks ago there was a clip of
Matt Gantz he was quoting a Chinese a
Chinese [__] propaganda rag yeah to a
witness and the witness is like whoa I I
you you can't anything that that paper
says you cannot use as evidence
well right it was Matt Gates said it so
confidently which we see that and you'll
see that with Lauren bobert here right
but he said it so confidently and the
guy was like he was like wait wait I
know what that's from is that from this
and my medication oh yeah yeah he goes
oh yeah he's like well I don't take
Chinese propaganda right but but this is
the this is but the problem is
listen it is a very difficult thing to
be a serious policy maker especially in
the United States House of
Representatives it's not easy now I mean
you can easily do it
stupidly and I'm going to show you that
here in just a second
I mean that's very easy to be stupid but
to be a serious policy maker and get
things done in our government you have
to understand things and not only that
you got to know everything
but you can't you're these people are
human our Congress people are human just
like you and me and everyone else they
can't know and be everywhere at all
times so they have to have really good
staffs like this is important that our
Congress people have very smart people
that know about policy especially you
know like specific policy
and then they can inform or at least
give them the information to be able to
talk intelligently about these things
but here's Lauren bobert now she's
questioning uh councilman for Washington
D.C the city right which our Congress
has a a stronghold over the city of D.C
because it's not in a state it's not a
state it's it's kind of of its own
little governments right kind of lives
out in la la land right which DC should
become part of a state I feel like [__]
that [__] make it part of a state or
make it its own State whatever you got
to do because this [__] is [__]
stupid where the city council has to
come and be questioned before the United
States Congress about [__] public
urination now in this place is what's
important to the Republicans right they
have to make it seem right like they're
doing work right right because they have
to prove
and also
there's all this talk of of this
Nashville shooting and the lack of of
prevention
and the Republican party has to show
that they're busy right we can't deal
with that right now that's not a real
problem you know it's a real problem
public urination and we need to go down
to the city level as a federal body
to investigate this because that's the
real crime
Kim asked Art says she got pissed on
that I don't I don't know when Jason
with the wine when he got it I don't
know that's what he was doing I have no
idea maybe that's why she's against
public urination but listen here how she
walks into a [__] her she walks
herself into a trap yeah who who is the
[__] staffer that gave her this
evidence that she's gonna talk about
somebody I so I I shared this yesterday
and somebody said I'm PR and this is
someone's comment they said I'm pretty
sure her staff hates her and I said well
they're doing a [__] bang-up job
that's if that's the case if they hate
her because you there's no way that
these people did not know this like
right well no I'm not I'm not gonna do
it I am I feel like the reason why is
because they're not they're not sure
about how any of these processes work
even at the very end she pisses me off
so [__] much when she says I yield no
you don't yield you yield
back you [__] bonehead it's yield
back it there is a clock and you take
part of it and you you have a certain
amount of time and when you have left
over you yield it back you [__] idiot
I just I can't I can't even hardly
[__] stand that part and how anyone
doesn't come up here and say Warren it's
yield back stop saying back your back
you're yielding back your time watch
watch as she embarrasses herself here
this is
it's [__] it's it's [__] hilarious
but I can't even believe that anyone in
Colorado and her District would watch
this video go what in the [__] did I
vote for her for let's let's watch it Mr
Allen
based on these statistics
I I would like to talk to you
um about some some other things um that
are going on here in Washington DC
specifically an initiative that you led
in November of 2022 you led the charge
to reform DC's crime laws is that
correct
I chaired the committee that that
proposal came you led this charge yes
sir and uh these charges these changes
are now law here in D.C correct
do you mean the revised criminal code
yes uh no those are not the law those
are not the law
did with these three guys revised
Governor code was uh rejected by excuse
me Mr chairman I talked to Mr Allen Mr
Allen did you or did you not
decriminalize public urination in
Washington DC did you lead the charge to
do so no it the revised criminal code
left that as a criminal charge did you
lead the charge to
decriminalize public urination in
Washington D.C no ma'am did you ever
vote in favor of decriminalizing public
urination in Washington DC the revised
criminal code did you ever support kept
it as a criminal offense did you did and
you support this Criminal I voted for it
yeah you voted to keep it as a criminal
offense that's correct the full council
did we have records that show that you
were in favor
of removing that criminal offense and
allowing public urination no the is that
something that you intend to pursue in
the future no the legislation you're
referring to that came from the criminal
code Reform Commission changed public
urination from a criminal to a civil
offense the council then changed that to
maintain it as a criminal offense at the
request of the mayor
thank you I yelled
thank you I yielded no thank you you'll
back you [__] [__] okay she was so
smug and confident she's like oh I got
you you voted and she's like well
according to records you voted this way
he's like all right
records we have we have records
[__]
we saw we saw like a scribble on a piece
of paper uh that you voted this way he's
like I did not vote that way at all I
don't know where you got that
information
for a party for a party that loves to
say do your own research they're really
bad at doing research they are [__]
terrible and now they're doing research
now that you're saying that about the
stamp maybe the staff hates her yeah I
maybe they're like you know we can do we
make her look like a fool [__] will go
viral I mean maybe you should have to
resign in an embarrassment Lauren bobert
suffers from uh foot and mouth syndrome
okay she she says the wrong thing at the
wrong time and then doubles down on it
and thinks that she's smarter that's
like when she she tried to call out uh
uh Rachel Maddow and say that uh
Democrats learned how to govern or the
sorry the Biden regime learned how to
govern from Rachel Maddow which first
off yeah that's she's [__] smart uh
she has a PHD teller she's a Rhodes
scholar not went to Rose College like
Amy Coney Barrett she's an actual Rhodes
scholar you know for anyone who
remembers the time when Kaylee mcinerney
tried to just slip that in there
um she's an actual Rhodes scholar she
has a PHD she is a [__] smart person
okay Lauren bobert is the complete
opposite so when she tries to own other
people like Rachel Maddow on Twitter and
talks about the Biden regime which would
be like I don't know authoritarian
government that tries to ban books or
strip rights away from women or those in
a community like the lgbtq community
that uh White straight religious people
are afraid of and fear
that sounds like a regime and then you
have Lauren bobert here in this moment
trying to own this guy be like well we
have records you totally voted this way
and he's like no I didn't I didn't vote
that way at all I have uh we can look at
the books we can look at the actual
voting record like I'm sure we could
bring in the person who was taking
minutes that day and they can read to
you that I didn't vote that way and
that's not the way in which you're
trying to make it seem and then at the
end she's like
okay well I yield
like I yield you [__] lost that
[__] pisses me off so much when she
says I yield
you you [__] [__] dude just it's
not that hard it's not that hard to
to know how to yield back your time you
[__] bonehead speaking of yielding
back time and taking back your time this
is how it's done you want you want to
see how it's done in a in a Committee
hearing we're gonna show you a few more
uh videos from the house here here's um
uh uh Moskowitz making a fool out of
Marjorie hoof foot green the petty Eddie
let's watch
is there any any question I'll yield to
anyone on this committee who disagrees
that murder in schools is not murdered
will you yield oh I'll yield yes please
yeah see this is how this is how you
actually yield
okay now watch Margaret watch Marjorie
Taylor green this is this is actually
how you do it this this is this is it
now he yields to Marjorie Taylor green
and watch how he takes back his time at
a certain moment is [__] beautiful
watch this and Marjorie Taylor green
walks straight into this walk he even he
even says who out there I'll yield back
Molly you back my time to you if you
want to speak because he knows it's his
clock right yeah it's his clock he can
yield his time to someone and then
he knows he can take it back and they
swipe watch this [__] yeah I was when I
was in 11th grade and Joe Biden made our
schools gun-free school zones one of us
which is a [__] lie brought three
guns to school and our entire school
went on lockdown that's a lie because he
was the only person with a gun there was
no good guy with a gun to protect us
kids at school you want to know why the
shooter is dead in Nashville the trans
shooter because they took a gun in a
school guy with a gun killed that woman
she identified as a man she was mentally
ill probably taking hormones watch this
and murdered children and adults in this
Christian school in Nashville so if you
want to have a good talk about schools
and protecting children we need to talk
about protecting our children the same
way we protect our President we protect
our celebrities
[Music]
you know there are six people that are
dead in that school including three
children because you guys got rid of the
assault weapons ban
because you guys made it easy for people
who don't deserve to have weapons who
are mentally incapable of having weapons
of war being able to buy those weapons
and go into schools I voted for sros in
my schools in in Florida after Parkland
we have sros on every school did the
good guys with the guns stop six people
from getting murdered no but you know
what AR-15s you've seen what those
bullets do to children you know why you
don't hunt with an AR-15 with a deer
because there's nothing left and there's
nothing left of these kids when people
go into school and murder them while
they're trying to read you guys are
worried about banning books dead kids
can't read
um
totally walked into that and let me tell
you something that is how you use how
you use proper procedure in a hearing
when these [__] idiots like Lauren
bobert or Marjorie Taylor green decide
they want to use oh yeah goddamn right
I'll talk into a microphone when they
when they don't know that they can be
shut up at them so do you want to know
some facts
yeah go ahead about this yeah all right
so uh are you talking about the margin
day the green thing yeah yeah I'll tell
you really quick so there is some truth
to the story
she did attend she was in high school at
uh at uh Forsyth County Georgia she was
an 11th grader at the time that the
shooter came in that is true okay
the shooter did come in did they hold
the bring the whole school in lockdown
no they didn't uh he took a group of
students in in and held them hostage uh
he was also going for the
trying to commit suicide uh death by cop
essentially
um now this story didn't come out until
2021 and you want to know why this story
came out in 2021 she never talked about
it never said anything so remember in uh
uh 2019 when she was harassing David
Hogg yeah and why this was before she
was elected before she was elected right
she is she was just she's just an
internet influencer she's just a person
on the internet with the [__]
conspiracy theory and when you keep an
honor uh-huh and she went and she talked
about how David Hogg and the rest of
those kids were uh crisis actors right
she she said it was paid by being paid
by George Soros and it's all an act and
this and this and that terrible things
so fast forward marjor Taylor green
becomes representative she now has to
kind of clean up her act a little bit uh
so that she's not as crazy so then she
says well when I was a student in
Georgia in in 1990 she started telling
the story in 2021 in February 2021 and
she starts to say uh look I'm I admit
that school shootings are real and that
David Hogg experienced a school shooting
which is the complete opposite of what
she said two years prior so now she's
[__] talking changing the story she's
backpedaling right so then in addition
to that so people are like whoa what's
the story coming out right so then
people started to do some fact checking
they did verify that she was a student
at that time the big thing that cannot
be verified is that whether or not she
was in attendance that day there are
some holes in her story of course
but the big ones are that uh Joe Biden
wasn't the president uh I'm pretty sure
there was a guy by the name of bush what
what year was this what year was T90 Oh
I thought because for Joe Biden to be
president or vice president it would
have had to been in the 2000s yeah you
would think I thought she was much older
January at the end of January 2021 that
this would be the case but according to
Lauren bobert it's Joe Biden no no no
Joe Biden Taylor green Marjorie Taylor
green
what do you mean
according to Marjorie Taylor no
according to Joe Biden is what I'm
saying uh he passed uh or bro I guess
according to Marty Taylor Greene
according to Marjorie Taylor green who
said Lauren bobert I'm saying sorry I
mean I mix them up all the time they're
both right idiots look according to
Roger Taylor green she said that Joe
Biden passed this law Joe Biden did not
even introduce this bill to the Senate
okay he did not even bring it in that
wasn't his Coast that was not his at all
uh so March each other Green's trying to
say that is Joe Biden's Bill he tried to
push us no it didn't also the uh
gun-free safety zone so the gun free
safe zones that were introduced to
schools that passed after the school
shooting happened so you you mean
nothing after the event at her school
happened yeah yeah so her and it was
under it was under Papa Bush that did
that he's the one who passed it and and
the and the gun free uh school zone Act
she's saying that was the cause of the
the reason yeah she's saying that
because it can't be the case right which
can't because it never passed at that
time it passed after the fact so she's
saying that the event that happened
Before the bill was passed
when Bush senior was president and Joe
Biden was Senator and he did not
introduce that bill
that it's all Joe Biden's fault and I
think in the House of Representatives at
that time
when it passed yeah there was only one
vote against it yeah the only one was
313 to one one
now the other thing that I saw it was
very it was very unpopular yeah it was
super unpopular which goes to show you
exactly we would not want guns at school
like that was right because you gotta
remember this is 1990 right two years
later two years later Ronald Reagan
Ronald listen to me when I tell you this
Ronald Reagan
they're [__] hero before Trump right
their God among Gods before Trump
went to the [__] capital and made
sure to get the assault weapons banned
the one that we talk about all the time
that [__] worked Ronald Reagan went
to the Capitol to Lobby he was a former
president he'd been shot as a president
damn near died as a result of gun
violence even though there was all these
armed guards around him
he went to the Capitol to Lobby senators
and Congress people to get the assault
weapons ban Over The Line in 1992 and he
was successful with the help of him and
Jimmy Carter
this this [__] ridiculous nonsense
where they go and they [__] wait was
that 92 or 94. the bill passed in 94.
did he go before that 92
who Reagan the the bill passed so the
bill was from
2004. okay why I believe it was in 1992
is when Reagan went before well maybe it
was 94. I [__] I don't know the point is
the point is is that Ronald Reagan their
God among Gods Went to went to [__]
Lobby for the assault weapons ban yeah
for it yeah he got the only reason the
only reason the only reason why the
assault weapons ban even passed was
because Ronald Reagan went right and now
you've got Steve scalise a Survivor who
nearly died in a 2017 mass shooting at a
congress baseball game or or practice I
forgot which one uh he got he got shot
he's a victim nearly died came back and
and uh after Uvaldi there's a clip of
him being like look we really got to
look at all the things that take place
right mental health is a big thing fast
forward
to this week when he goes look the first
thing I do is pray yeah I pray and it's
like okay you can pray but you also
better [__] do some [__] about it how
them prayers work for you buddy when you
got shot uh damn near killed Steve
scalise yeah and you killed him well as
far as Steve scalise goes [__] that dude
now David points out something here he
says today's anniversary uh of the
Ronald Reagan shooting that's oh wow I
guess you know they're right yeah I'm
always on top of everything Republicans
will use that if it's brought up they'll
use it to their advantage to say well
you know what the best way to honor
Ronald Reagan is to make sure that our
Second Amendment right isn't taken away
whoa I don't know Ronald Reagan those
bullets were woke and went into Ronald
Reagan I mean
the Republican Party truly is something
it's it's disgusting really the fact
that they're able to just not give a
damn
even when
and also by the way there's some new
developments on this Nashville shooting
oh really okay well
um we can we can go into tomorrow yeah
we'll get into it tomorrow yeah I want
to show you this clip um speaking of uh
Republicans and dunking them in the
trash and this is
this is how you do it right here watch
this this is this is a great clip too
tacking those platforms attempts to
combat misinformation the plaintiffs in
cases like Missouri V Biden do
disservice to the principles of free
speech that they claim to support and
they invite the grave consequences of
misinformation that they seek to spread
themselves unchecked
it is perhaps not a coincidence that the
proponents of measures that would
handicap social media platforms efforts
to combat misinformation are often
prolific purveyors of misinformation
themselves
Senator Schmidt and attorney general
Landry who just testified filed the
brief in the Supreme Court supporting a
suit by the state of Texas seeking to
block the accounting of electoral votes
of from four states that President Biden
won over a hundred members of Congress
including members of this committee
today also filed brief supporting that
suit
Texas's complaint included a Fantastical
claim that the statistical likelihood
that President Biden fairly won the 2020
election was less than one in
quadrillion that is false
members of this committee have claimed
that Dominion voting machines
fraudulently flipped votes from Trump to
Biden
that is false
members of this committee have claimed
that thousands of ballots were cast on
behalf of dead and unqualified voters
that is false
members of this committee have claimed
that election workers around the country
counted fake or fraudulent votes that is
false
and on October 19 2020 chairman Jordan
tweeted that Democrats are trying to
steal the election after the election
that is false
lies like these corrode Americans faith
in the Integrity of our elections and
our democracy those elections are
without question fundamentally sound
these falsehoods formed the foundation
of an unprecedented effort to reverse
the results of a presidential election
and they are just a drop in the bucket a
drop in the ocean of the flood of lies
that flooded social media in the weeks
and months after the
that is beautiful folks that is
beautiful and if you want if you want to
memorize that you can if you got your
uncle he's like ah the election was
stolen you just just throw that at him
just a little bit or just have it handy
on your phone to [__] dunk them in
the trash boy I got some more Clips I'd
love to show you but I have to go um
take a nap and take it yeah drop the
kitties off at the pool
not the bowling alley but the pool no no
oh but you know what no I gotta show you
this one last clip it's only 35 seconds
long I'm I'm loving her more and more
every day watch this watch this one oh I
think an attorney general Jeff Landry
where he decries all political violence
and calls for an end to that and uh asks
for respect for all political viewpoints
without objection another thing we can
examine because he's not here uh there
you go you can examine it it's a
document he's gonna examine him for what
he wrote and the intent behind what he
said well I would just okay I would just
point out that that's that's uh watch
this [__] consensus for documents and we
got the document right here Mr chairman
I would ask you
I have a unanimous oh my God
Miss Plaskett you are my hero dude the
fact he drops it down and she goes I'm
sorry the [__] the [__] you do and then
she picked up that she picked up that
letter or that document whatever is that
what whatever's there and then put it
back and was like don't you ever [__]
do this again you better respect me and
the position I hold yeah because I will
[__] own you in this committee do it
again I dare you like it's just it's
just it's you telling you beautiful I I
cannot wait I cannot wait for Plaskett
to be in leadership in the Democratic
party and she is in the perfect position
standing right next to Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan it is hilarious
that she schools these [__]
every day oh every day and it's awesome
she is a badass [__] bad ass
[__] and I love her for it and
that and the fact that she took that
paper is like hey you know what you can
do it you need to stick this straight up
your [__] ass she's like I don't give
a [__] about this thing that you're
trying to push right and don't you dare
think that you have the ability
the privilege to do that you better
[__] put yourself back in your chair
and stay over there for the rest of this
hearing and you know what going forward
you better not get up and do this [__]
ever again
because guess what I am now your worst
[__] nightmare
like that's just like she doesn't give a
[__] and I I I I I commend that and I
think that's [__] awesome and we
should do more of that we have Jamal
Bowman we you know we have this
situation like this is something that
team Jefferies I mean Jeffries this is
[__] where we have to say you know what
we're fed up we are now in a position
where we cannot
sit by anymore we have to speak up we
have to call them out we have to say no
no no no your [__] is [__] and
it's wrong and it can be stopped and it
needs to be stopped and you need to be
voted out like all these big you know
[__] Josh Hawley trying to push this
anti-crip or he's trying to push this
crime investigation
which a little a little bit of a little
bit of a snippet for we'll talk about
tomorrow turns out right because Josh
Hawley and other people are making it's
a it's a it's a it's a it's a hate crime
it's this this is that
it's now being revealed that the shooter
was under counseling by the pastor
and so it looks like because the
pastor's daughter was killed and it
sounds like the shooter was going to the
school to find
the pastor so I don't know again I don't
know what the pastor did or what the
relationship was or what have you but we
also have to remember that it does have
a history of sexual abuse not saying
that that's what this is
but the situation from the beginning
seemed a little weird and so the fact
that the shooter went to that school
sounds like the shooter was looking for
the pastor for whatever happened
wheosh well I'm excited to get to the
bottom of that I I because I think that
and the reason why is because that will
give people a better understanding of
why this person had access to guns
if this person in law enforcement I
forget I think it was a chief of police
here in Nashville
um seven guns legally purchased in the
state of Tennessee and and the the
police the chief police there said hey
um the the the reason why we couldn't
stop this is because no one notifies us
when a person
who is under counseling
get tries to buy a firearm if we would
have known we would have taken these
guns away from this person but we have
no way of knowing you have to pass laws
for us to know is what he's trying to
say yeah there's a thing called a red
flag might want to look into it so my so
my excitement here is because we're go
we should politicize the ever loving
[__] out of it folks this is how policy
works you politicize issues to get
policy that's how you do it I got so
many videos I want to show you but
tomorrow we do it tomorrow once you take
your [__] tomorrow yeah I gotta go I
gotta go take take care of my hangover
everybody thanks for sticking through
the show today even though in the very
beginning I was a little drunk still I I
well I I'm hungover now I was
still swimming in Jagermeister
um so at the same time same place
tomorrow
Surfs Up [__] Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon